-You're very different
from Donald Trump.
I think one distinction you draw
is, again, you've even sai
you want to meet him
on a field of love
as opposed to a field of hate.
So that is a difference
between you.
A similarity is neither of you
have ever held political office.
And obviously, there is some
hesitation by many voters
that that is an important thin
that you lack.
What do you say to them?
-Well, the question
is legitimate,
but I think my answer
is significant as well.
First of all,
the problem with the President
is not that he lacked
experience.
The problem with the President
is that he lacks ethics.
And he seems to lack
a visceral taste for democracy
He lacks a visceral respec
for our democratic traditions.
I do not.
Now, as far as political
experience is concerned,
and he could have
surrounded himself
with very fine political experts
had he chosen to.
Now, when you -- I have a lot of
respect for political expertise,
but let's not kid ourselves.
Very experienced politicians
led us into the war in Iraq.
led us into the war in Vietnam
We need political vision now
as much as we need
political expertise.
You could have the best
car mechanic in the world,
but the best car mechanic
doesn't necessarily know
what road you should take
to San Antonio.
That's what I feel I bring
And FDR said that
the primary responsibility
and the primary role
of the presidency, he said
is not the administrative
aspect.
That, he said, is secondary.
The primary role
is moral leadership.
That is what we lack.
We lack a vision of
where America is
and a vision of
where America needs to go.
And that takes more than
political expertise,
and I believe that
the experience I do have
and the skill set I do hav
makes me the woman for that job.
-So you would be in this cas
GPS, basically.
[ Laughter ]
-But you know what?
That is what the presidency is
-Yeah, I can see that argument
-That is what the presiden
does.
The president doesn't sit ther
with a checkbook
and try to figure it all out
-No, certainly not this one.
[ Laughter ]
You received some criticis
for a couple comments,
comments that you have walke
back and said were misstated
and that people would say
were maybe anti-science.
You came out, you made a comment
against antidepressants.
You made a comment
that many saw as anti-vaxx
Did you -- Were those mis-
Did you misspeak
or have your opinions
on those things evolved?
-No, they've been inaccurately
described, as you just did
I never made a comment
anti-antidepressants.
I've never said anything
anti-science.
anti-medicine.
I've actually never said
anything anti-vaccines.
What I have said,
the first thing I said,
and I did misspeak.
I was at an art gallery
in New Hampshire,
and the comment was about
mandatory vaccines.
And I spent most of
my adult life in California.
There's been
a lot of conversation
about religious exemptions
personal exemptions,
and I said something
that I am sorry that I said.
I said they sound -- it sounds
Orwellian or Draconian to me
I should not have said that,
and I am sorry.
That was not
an anti-vaxx statement.
Now, about antidepressants -
painkillers, for instance,
have a role but we now know.
We have attorney generals
all over this country
who are right now indictin
big pharmaceutical
company executives
for predatory behavior,
where we absolutely know now
they knowingly overprescribed,
over-manufactured,
and over-marketed opioids,
and that's how
so much that has contributed
to the opioid crisis.
Now, just like painkillers
certainly have a role,
I'm sure antidepressants
clearly have a role
in some people's lives.
But we're living at a time
where the spectrum
of normal human despair
is so often treated
or at least the conversation
is there about meds
that I do question.
If somebody had a divorce
or a heartbreak or someone die
or a professional failure
or a bankruptcy,
this is painful,
but it's not a mental illness.
And these drugs
are mainly addictive,
and I am not the only person
in mainstream America
to be questioning
the over-prescription of -
that there is
at least as much question
about over-prescription
as about under-prescription.
I'm not wandering into menta
illness, bipolar, schizophrenia.
That's not my lane,
but normal human despair
is the lane of someone
who does the kind of work
that I have done.
-Well, thank you so much
for explaining that.
I want to say you've not yet
qualified for September debates.
Are you confident that you will?
-Well, anybody can go
to marianne2020.com.
[ Laughter ]
I need about 6,000 more
of the donors,
first-time donors,
before August 28th,
and we're certainly
on track to get that,
and I also need 2%
of 4 national polls.
So we'll see.
We'll probably know somethin
in the next few days.
-Alright. Well, thank you
so much for making the time.
-Thank you.
-Best of luck.
I really appreciate
speaking to you.
Marianne Williamson, everybody